okay that was the multiple choice let's
now dive
into the extended response so here comes
question five
part a we begin with some geometry on
the complex plane
triangle abc is an equilateral triangle
so there it is there
uh it looks vaguely equilateral lots of
scale
you've got points a and b um which
represent the complex numbers
6 plus 4i and negative 6 minus
4i so let's go ahead and we can put that
information onto our diagram you've got
6 plus 4i over here
and then you've got negative 6
minus 4i over here yeah the scale's not
amazing but it'll it'll do us fine okay
find in cartesian form and you had to
give geometric reasons which is why this
question attracts
so many marks find in cartesian form the
complex
number represented by c down here so
this is my target
in the diagram okay so how do i find
this now
the first thing i'm going to say and
this was this is the first occasion to
say it
but i'm i'm going to state it now so i
don't have to restate it every single
time we encounter a question like this
the geometry um throughout this paper
was done very poorly
now it wasn't just because people looked
at this and they were like you know i
i'm going to skip this i'll come back to
later i ran out of time
it was incredible how many people tried
to solve questions like this
without drawing their own diagram now i
know you can
put information onto the diagram that's
provided that's fine that's definitely
better than
not using a diagram at all but even
looking at question papers and seeing
that very little constructions were
added
there was very little evidence that
students were using the diagram
effectively
that was a big problem and to be honest
with a question like this
drawing a diagram yourself is often
number one
the first step in understanding what's
going on and therefore knowing
what path you're going to take through
your proof and number two
it's part of you communicating your
answer if you have done all of your
working on this diagram
which then subsequently is not submitted
as part of your solution
then how do you expect a marker to be
able to understand
the line of reasoning that you've taken
the logic
you know at least in some of the proofs
i'm about to show you i had to add on
create new points or new intervals and
things like that and
if you're just drawing stuff onto the
diagram on the paper
or worse still you just have like a
diagram in your head that you're trying
to reason through
the marker sees none of that so you're
not communicating
your reasoning which is kind of the
point of this question um
through your solutions so that was
something done consistently poorly
throughout the task um
even when diagrams were drawn they were
very very small
and so it made it hard for you to know
what was going on and it also made it
hard for you to communicate to the
marker
what you were trying to say off of your
diagram so
i'm not going to keep restating that but
this
particular error comes up a lot and it's
not just an extension 2 problem this
happens in extension one and it happens
in advanced
so please take major notice of the fact
that geometry questions have to be done
uh not just with much more care but
please think about
how you are communicating visual
information
the best way to do it is visually draw
me a good diagram
okay how do you work out a path through
this question i'm going to show you
three different solutions for this in
increasing order of messiness uh you
know
i i actually i got help from other
people to have a look at you know how
would you solve this
um i'm going to tell you right now the
first solution i came up with was not
particularly elegant
but often under exam conditions that's
the way it is you come with a solution
you're like
maybe it's not the most beautiful one
but i'm going to show you there are
better ways to solve this and why
so let's have a look at the first
solution
i'm going to say right from the outset
uh it's not an
intuitive solution for most people but
i'm showing it to you first because
it's remarkably elegant it's a really
fantastic solution
and even if you didn't think of it first
i want you to think of it in the future
because the basic strategy that it uses
is very clever
and it often can make things easier so
let me get the question out of the way
remember what we're trying to find is c
we know it's an equilateral triangle we
know where a is we know where b
is how do we find c the first solution
approach
is to introduce a translation what does
that mean
as you might be able to see from this
diagram which by the way it also
includes the second part of the question
which we'll get to later
the idea of translation is to slide
around the points and intervals on our
diagram
to preserve directions and lengths but
to move them into a different position
because sometimes a different position
is just easier to work with and you can
see what this solution has done
it has moved one of our original points
between a and b you could have done
either would have been equivalent
but it's moved b um from where it was
which was
a negative 6 minus 4i it was over here
in the third quadrant
and it has shifted it over to the origin
so now you can see what i've labeled
here is
b a c and we eventually get to
p i've placed them all in their new
positions and i've given them a
subscript of t
to stand for translated so now this new
version of b is on the origin this new
version of a
it's been shifted over to 12 plus 8i and
c has also been shifted as well so once
i find out where c is
to find the the real c not the
translated c i'm obviously gonna have to
shift it back
um same deal for p as well so once i do
that you can see over here in my working
and it's also critical that i don't just
do this on the diagram and then
hope that whoever's reading my um uh
my working is gonna say oh they must
have you know translated things right
if i saw this diagram without any kind
of verbal explanation of what was
happening
i would just say you have solved a
different question
this is not the question that i provided
to you so if you're going to make some
fundamental change
like this and it's just the same as if
you're in some other question and you
know you got presented with
um you know something like uh solve for
x and you got given
let's see here uh 2 to the x plus
5 lots of 2 to the x
minus 6 equals 0 solve this equation for
x
what would you do here well you would i
hope recognize that this is not a
quadratic equation
sorry this should be it's a bit cheeky
isn't it that's what happens when i make
up a question on the fly
there should be an extra 2 here this is
not a quadratic equation
but with a simple substitution i can
reduce this to a quadratic equation
uh what would i do here i would want to
get this into the form uh u
squared plus 5u minus
6 equals 0 because i can use all the
tools i know in quadratic
equations to solve this but you wouldn't
just write this because you have just
fundamentally changed the question
u squared plus 5u minus 6 equals 0 is
substantially easier to solve
i have to show the connection between
the question you gave me and the
question
i am now solving i would have to say let
u
equal to the x because our number one
communicates to the marker what i'm
doing number two
it reminds me i've just made this
substitution
i'm going to have to unsubstitute this
at the end in order to
restore back the question i was supposed
to solve right so
it's the same deal here right in
geometry as as in algebra if you make
some change
tell me what you're doing right now
since all i've done is translated things
around i haven't changed uh
proportions or lengths or anything like
that my new triangle a b
c or a t b t c t which is a bit of a
mouthful
that new triangle is also equilateral
you take an equilateral triangle and you
shift it around it's still equilateral
so it's
still equilateral that means what i can
do is i can say
this bc i'm going to stop using
the t's because i think you can see it
there this bc can be found
by rotating ba
clockwise by pi on 3 radians so you can
see
here this this is the rotation
that i'm doing i'm thinking about taking
this is probably going to be too thick
so let's just take it here this is
b a and when i rotate it
pi on 3 radians clockwise
you can see that's what brings me down
to let's use the right color
that's what brings me down to b c
and of course i know that it's pion 3
radians because atrial
equilateral triangles all of the angles
are pi on 3
radians so therefore i can write pi on 3
there okay
so how do i do that um how do you take a
complex number or rather a vector bc
that's represented by a complex number
and rotate it well you take that complex
number 12 plus 8i
and in we know in complex arithmetic the
way that you
achieve rotation is by multiplication of
the appropriate number
right so you can see here i've chosen
this number
uh i'll highlight it um
cos actually i'm using the wrong color
because i should use the color that i
highlighted before
i'm doing this because of negative part
3 plus i sine negative pi on 3.
cos of negative pi on 3 plus i sine
negative pi on 3 is a complex number
it has a modulus of one i want a modulus
of one because
when i multiply i don't want this um i
don't want this b
a to get any longer or shorter so i want
its magnitude its modulus to stay the
same
so this modulus here is one but then its
argument
is negative pi on 3. if i were to put pi
on 3 there i would rotate
pi on 3 radians anti-clockwise because
that's how i measure angles that's the
default direction for measuring angles
on the complex plane i want to go
clockwise
not anticlockwise so that's why you can
see i've got negative pi and three as
the arguments that are in there
okay now um even though i write this to
make clear like that's how i do this gmh
transformation
i don't want to keep in polar form i
don't want to keep in trigonometric form
because
um it makes the multiplication hard and
messy right
i i need to work out what is cos of
negative pi on 3
it's a half what is
i sine of negative pi on 3 it's going to
be negative root 3 on 2
times i so i've just changed that into
rectangular form
because then i can multiply through i
notice
on this line here i've got a common
factor of a half on this right hand
complex number so you can see what i'm
doing is i'm multiplying this by half
because they're all even numbers anyway
i've got this then i'm expanding out so
you can see this is me
this is me multiplying by 1. this is me
multiplying by
negative root 3i so you can see i've got
the i there which comes from uh
6 times negative root 3i and then i've
got an i squared because you've got to
watch out
for those terms there and then what have
i done
you can see here just be careful this
negative 4 root 3 i squared
it comes down over here because
that i squared or rather that negative i
squared becomes a positive 1.
so that's where i get this term you can
see
where i've got this um this six just
slides down
into this six and then lastly
let's see if i can fit it in here this
uh in fact i don't really need to write
anything
too complicated draw lots of arrows this
4i
minus 6 root 3 i all i need to do is
just factor out
this i over here and that leaves me with
4 minus 6 root 3.
so what has this achieved well i found
where
c is in this translated scheme i
remember i moved everything
six units to the right and four units up
so therefore having done that and solved
where c is in this translated scheme
i have to undo that translation so i
added 6
plus 4i to everything so now i'm undoing
that i'm i subtract
6 plus 4i and that gives me this which
very conveniently it's almost like it
was designed to do this
gets rid of that 6 and that 4i you can
see there
so this is my answer for part c sorry
for point c rather
now um i know lots of you will say
who on earth would think to just take a
diagram and just change everything like
move everything to different spots
i certainly would have wouldn't think of
that well two things number one
i hope in the future you now will
contemplate this as a potential option
moving things on to the origin is a
classic example of
taking a problem and simplifying some
part of it
so that it becomes easier to solve and
then taking the lessons you learned from
that simpler problem
and then applying them to your original
more complicated problem
mathematicians use this all the time
it's a fantastic technique
but totally solvable without thinking of
this amazing
unusual insight i've got two more
solutions one which is
pretty pretty good i think and i i know
that
a few of you attempted this and then one
which is a bit of a mess but it works
anyway
and it just shows you the flexibility
that you have in solving this so let's
have a look at method two
which is to use some right angled
triangle trigonometry
so you can see what i've got here is my
original diagram a where it was b where
it was and c
where it needs to be and what i notice
is if i do this construction in here i
take this
point here the origin and i join an
interval over here to
c what i've done is i've divided up my
equilateral triangle
into two congruent halves i've got aoc
over here and this is congruent to boc
over here um and you know this is
extension two so it's we're pretty fine
for you not to do the entire proof
of why these are congruent triangles but
it's not hard to see
right these two intervals here um
ao and bo are going to be equal to each
other because of the coordinates of a
and b oc is going to be a common side
and then because abc is equilateral i've
got bc being equal to
ac which are those outside lengths
so i've got two congruent triangles what
does that enable me to do it shows me
that aoc
has to be equal to boc and because these
are angles on a straight line
they add up to pi radians that's what
i've got
right here and because i'm just
splitting this into two
angles they're each going to be pi on
two so this is a right angle triangle
and that enables me to do some right
angle triangle trig
once you've done that you can notice
that you've got this part three just
like we noticed before it's just i'm now
looking at a different angle
so that's pi on three that's my pion two
there's a pine six down here which we
don't really need
i can say hold up since this is pion3
over here
and i know what this length uh ao is
equal to
um i can relate that to oc
this length by using the appropriate
trigonometric ratio
i can say hold on a second in relation
to
angle cao this pi on 3 right
i've got oc being the opposite side
over here and i've got let's choose a
different color
i've got ao being my adjacent side so
what is the appropriate ratio here you
might have seen when i scroll down
it's going to be tan right so you can
see i've written here
in this right angle triangle tan of pi
on three which is my corner angle is
opposite
on adjacent oc on oa and you can notice
here i'm using the appropriate
um language here to say our notation
rather it's not oc the vector
it's the magnitude of oc um tan doesn't
care about
uh this is a ratio of lengths not a
ratio of vectors with direction
right because these are going in very
different directions and that doesn't
matter to me
okay very very minor note for those of
you who were doing this
um some of you jumped into just saying
10 pi on 3 it just equals this or
you know 10 pi on 6 if you use the
corner angle
it is really helpful it's really clear
if you can say to me
well hold on a second why would i even
say tan of parliament three and the
answer is
i'm in a right angled triangle which i
reasoned up above and that's why i can
say this
okay so that just makes your is it
necessary no
but it makes your reasoning much easier
to actually follow
and that can often make the difference
sometimes it is just really difficult to
know
what were you talking about what were
you reaching for where does your logic
flow so once you've got that i know what
10 pi on 3 is because that's an exact
angle
an exact value i should say so that's
root 3. so i've got this ratio equals
root 3.
i multiply this length over here
a over to the other side because what
i'm trying to find is
oc and the thing is i know
that i can work out what
that is going to be equal to by saying
hold on a second aoc is this right angle
triangle here right
so therefore i can say oc is going to be
root 3 because that's its magnitude
multiplied by negative i
that rotates me pi on 2 radians
in the clockwise direction
and then oh a i multiply by that because
it's essentially taking this right and
lengthening it
root three over here you see that's
that's the ratio right this
length oc is root three times longer
than o eight so i don't even
need to know how long o a is i just need
to know that oc
is root 3 times longer than it and
that's going to give me it's going to
stretch out oa
and send it in the correct direction so
that's going to give me this arithmetic
here so the
root 3 and the negative i are here
there's
oa it's by definition 6 plus 4i
i've just multiplied through and then
i've just tied it up and you can see
i get the same answer that i got in
method one
so as mentioned several people uh gave
this a go and i think it was
a pretty good solution but many of you
didn't even get to hear partly because
you didn't draw a diagram yourself
and so you couldn't reason through what
can i add to this diagram
that will help me okay i'm going to show
you a
third and final method now um it's it's
rather long
and messy uh but i actually kind of like
it because it just shows you
um how many different approaches you can
take to these geometry questions
and uh that's one of the wonderful
things that mathematical thinker equips
us to do
show us multiple solution paths to a
single problem so
i call this by midpoints what am i doing
here
well in order to get to point c
we could use right angle triangle trig
like we did before or
we could use kind of the existing
vectors that we have in order to reason
through this now
um you can i will float through this the
working of it
um you know so that you can read it in
your own link you can just pause the
video and read it you can see exactly
how
i set it out but let me just show you
how it works on the diagram itself
how do i get to c by use of some
midpoints okay well i notice that
o is the midpoint of a b right so if i
have a think about
o a it is a vector
from the midpoint to one of the vertices
in this case from o
to a now what i can do is i can take
that and if i
uh not translate if i rotate that by pi
on 3 radians
if i do this this clockwise rotation
that you've seen me already do once
before
that gives me this and by using some
circle
not circle some triangle geometry
properties
i can say this is actually going to take
me it's going to create this little
equilateral triangle up here this is
going to be the midpoint of
a c and that's really helpful to me
because i can use that fact
in order to take this this om vector
which i get by multiplying through
by that cos negative pi on 3 plus
i sine negative pi 3 that you saw before
that's going to give me om
and what you can see i hope is that it's
easy to reason this and you'll see this
in my written form here
om that displacement vector
is going to be it's actually a position
vector but every position vector is also
a displacement vector
it's going to be the same as the
position vector b q
and because it's to the midpoint it's
also going to be identical to the
displacement vector of q c
so once i work out om all i need to do
is then add that vector twice to b
or i should say ob because what that
will do is it will take you from
o to b then it will take you from b
to q and then from q to c which is what
i actually
want so when you have a look at the
working this is the part where i'm
working out
m so it's because you can see i'm
multiplying through
to get the vector om it does end up a
bit of a mess but that's fine it does
actually simplify out
that's how you find m and then once i do
that i say
okay well let's go to b and then do this
om vector twice that's going to take you
over to
c so you can follow this arithmetic
yourself and since oc is a position
vector
once you find this position vector c is
just given by
that point 4 3 minus 6 root 3 i and
you're done
so that is three different ways to have
a go
at part one if we come back to the
question paper just briefly you can see
where we have to go from there is then
to say once you know where
c is imagine there is some point p that
represents the complex number
little p that's positioned to make a
rhombus right and they tell you
that p is between its argument is
between negative pi
and negative pi on 2. so where is that
you can see that's going to put you in
the fourth
quadrant because here would be an
argument of negative pi on 2
here would be an argument of negative pi
so i'm going to be
somewhere down here that's you know i've
just shaded in purple all of the points
that have
this range for the argument so the
reason why this has to be specified is
because
p could otherwise be in other locations
you know you could put p over here or
over here
i want that position that point p to be
down here
which is why if i just come back to my
diagrams over here
and let's just have a look at one of
them you can see i've drawn p over here
how did i get to that well once you've
got position c
or point c rather if you know a b
to make this a rhombus uh vector a
b is going to be identical uh as a
displacement vector to c
p that's really easy to work out though
it's negative 12 minus 8i as i've
written here
i've got to go to the left 12 units and
then i've got to go down
8 units so this is the appropriate
vector i just need to apply that
to point c i need to add those together
because that will take me
from o to c and then from c to p
so if you have a look at my working uh
down here
this is me saying look the opposite
sides of the rhombus are equal and
parallel
they're equal which means the magnitude
of the vectors is the same they're
parallel which means the direction of
the vectors is the same so
that's what makes vectors equal to each
other and then i can say by addition of
vectors to get to p
go to c first then go from c to p
going from c to p is the same as going
from a to b and then off you go
you get this result down here slightly
messy but that's the answer